[Music]
dr. Edwards Deming said if you can't
describe work as a process you can't
improve it one of the most powerful and
accessible process improvement tools we
have to learn with is something called a
process map a process map is a visual
display of the activities of a process
or a system process maps are extremely
useful and helpful for understanding how
a current process is designed by
enabling you to quickly identify
opportunities for improvement once a
process has been improved process Maps
can also act as guidance to support
people doing standard work and following
a designed process reliably process
mapping is a powerful exercise for
learning and improving I often describe
it as one of the secret weapons for
helping teams to identify variation and
potential failure points in their work
processes in an ideal scenario I like to
do process mapping with a mixed group of
stakeholders of the process we're trying
to improve I also strive to go to where
work happens versus doing it in a
conference room or a meeting space I
begin by inviting the team to think
about the average patient or someone who
represents the normal population this
process must serve every day then I ask
them to attempt to describe the process
at a macro level as high level as
possible so let's take an example here
and draw just a simple diagram so
usually every process has a start and
the start in the end often use a shape
that looks like a pill and then what you
do is you start to ask yourself what are
each of the steps in the process and so
we might go and say well here's step one
the box there and step two and step
three and and maybe after step three
there's actually a decision that has to
be made so we reflect that by making it
a diamond and that may bring us to an
extra process step down here so if yes
for example it may continue on I'll put
a little Y here or just right yes it'll
continue on
down the process if it's no then there
might be a decision to go down here and
fix something before the process
continues and then we keep going until
we reach the end and again at the end we
often describe it as a pill so each step
along the way right we've got process
step one and two and three and then
there was a decision that had to be made
and so that either takes us to step four
or it drops us down here to this step
before we move up to four but it's
basically a simple visual display of the
steps in a process from start to finish
now in my experience most teams won't
make it past the first step or the
second step in a process before they
start describing multiple ways a step
can be done or they just disagree on
what the step is or identify a failure
point all of this is fantastic for
generating improvement ideas this
dialogue and listening here is essential
for learning and I try to balance
keeping people focused on getting to a
first draft process and honoring and
capturing all of the input from team
members there are a number of different
approaches you can take in doing a
process map from the very basic
hand-drawn flow diagram on a whiteboard
or a piece of paper like I just did to
more complex variations including value
stream analysis spaghetti diagrams
swimlane diagrams each helps us
understand better how work actually
happens process mapping is a great tool
think about a process you want to better
understand and see if you can map it out
from start to finish
you